you
okay so in the final scene of Kill Bill
Vol - by Quentin Tarantino the eponymous
villain bill tranquilizes the hero and
the narrative to deliver a short
monologue on his deep affection for
comic book superheroes namely Superman
the Man of Steel he says stands apart
from other heroes like Batman spider-man
etc in that unlike those others who have
to Don the costume that they may become
the hero
Superman wakes as Superman and must
instead Don the costume of Clark Kent
the mild-mannered reporter from The
Daily Planet who bill believes is
Superman's critique on the human race
now I don't know if Tarantino believes
this or it's just Bill who does but
being a huge fan of Superman I have to
say that I can't agree with this
characterization of the last Son of
Krypton not too long ago when I didn't
have to pay for rent for utilities or
groceries or car insurance I used to
read comic books every Wednesday I'd go
to the local comic book store and pick
up new editions of the DC monthlies
mainly the for Superman titles which
were at that time still running Action
Comics Superman The Adventures of
Superman and the Man of Steel I was the
only one of my friends who read comics
regularly and so it was sort of a thrill
going there every Wednesday because it
was my first real sense of a community
in which everyone was connected by their
love of something in this case comics
and I've been a huge fan of communities
like that ever since
hence anyway I became fascinated with
Superman probably for the same reason
that a lot of young boys do they get
lost in that fantasy of unlimited
physical power Superman could fly and it
is an immutable fact of the universe
that every boy everywhere knows exactly
which combination of muscles to clench
in order to take off into the sky or
shoot fire from your eyes or see through
walls Superman could do all those things
he could fly SuperSpeed hear cries for
help at great distances he could pick up
cars and hurl them like baseballs and
how cruel were the stupid stupid laws of
physics for preventing all us regular
humans from doing such things when it's
so easy to imagine I don't think that
those fantasies ever leave us but as I
grew older the story of Superman began
to captivate me for different reasons I
think when we're young we feel that to
achieve those feats of strength would
solve a lot of our problems if I could
only fly if I could be the one who flies
that I could be special and important in
all those abstract things but as we make
our way through adolescence
the complexities of the inner life begin
to muddy those waters the pen with which
you had to write your own identity gets
put into your hand and you realize that
no feat of strength or speed will help
you with that task for Superman the task
would be even more difficult his
strength is speed his ability to fly
serve only to neutralize the physical so
that the intellectual and emotional
problems that plagued all of us how to
love how to be loved how to know who we
are what we should want how we should
act why we're here appear only in
starker relief all his incredible power
becomes an equally incredible
helplessness Clark Kent can't wake up
free from these things just as neither
you nor I can ignore the personal and
ethical dilemmas that define us and it's
ironic that in the comics his feelings
of being an alien from another planet of
not fitting in are the cause of so much
sorrow because it is these same feelings
of sorrow for not fitting in for not
belonging that make the rest of us human
Clark Kent is Clark Kent he puts on the
costume to become Superman it is as
godly and perfect as we would have
others believe that we are he saves the
world from extraterrestrial existential
threats from villains of every shape
size and hairstyle yet he is as impotent
as the rest of us when it comes to
saving himself from the bumbling
stuttering forever struggling condition
of life and maybe Clark Kent as Clark
Kent's critique on the human race but to
say that is simply to say that we are
all continuously critiquing the human
race when we for example make total
fools of ourselves in front of the Lois
Lane's of our lives and as beautiful as
Lois seems to Clark we know that she
herself feels inadequate in the presence
of Superman the great hero who is after
all only the same Clark Kent who's
invincible needs
can't seem to keep from going weak in
the presence of her kryptonite eyes some
critique
yeah